[Música]
revivir la unasur Ese fue el objetivo de
la Cumbre que reunió a 11 líderes
latinoamericanos en Brasilia este 30 de
mayo casi una década después de su
decaída por divisiones ideológicas y de
Derechos Humanos en torno a la figura de
Nicolás maduro en Venezuela el encuentro
para auspiciar el acercamiento comercial
y diplomático terminó con una
declaración conjunta que expresó
compromiso con la democracia con los
derechos humanos con el desarrollo
sostenible y con la justicia social Pero
sin injerencia en los asuntos internos
de los demás sin embargo Venezuela sigue
siendo un foco de discordia Mi nombre es
Ángela Gómez y este es el debate de
France 24 para abrir el camino a nuestra
discusión de hoy primero los quiero
invitar a ver nuestro reporte sobre el
tema
los líderes de once países reunidos en
Brasilia la capital de Brasil con un
objetivo reafianzar la unidad de
Sudamérica una propuesta del presidente
de izquierdas Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
mientras estemos divididos no haremos de
Sudamérica un continente desarrollado
con todo su potencial
la integración la integración debe ser
el objetivo permanente de todos nosotros
tenemos que plantar raíces fuertes para
la futura generaciones
Esta no es una tarea sencilla ya que hay
algunas reticencias especialmente en
torno a una figura la de presidente de
Venezuela Nicolás maduro y es que
actualmente hay una Clara división entre
los países sudamericanos respecto a la
reaparición de maduro en la Esfera
internacional mientras que algunos como
Brasil Argentina o Colombia están a
favor de su reintegración otros como
chile o Uruguay no lo ven con tan buenos
ojos
en el sentido en que la situación de
Derechos Humanos en Venezuela era una
construcción narrativa no es una
construcción narrativa es una realidad
es seria sorprendido
cuando se habló de lo que sucede en
Venezuela es una narrativa lo peor que
podemos hacer es tapar el sol con un
dedo
pongámosle el nombre que tiene y
ayudemos pero a pesar de las divisiones
se espera que en las Naciones
suramericanas dialoguen sobre un nuevo
mecanismo de integración regional
inspirado en la antigua unasur ideada
por Lula y el expresidente Hugo Chávez
en 2008 pero que quedó desmantelada con
el auge de los presidentes conservadores
en la región para analizar el tema de
hoy nos acompaña desde San José Costa
Rica José
Borbón ella es secretaria general de la
facultad latinoamericana de ciencias
sociales flacso y desde Vancouver Canadá
está la doctora Grace Jaramillo ella es
profesora en la escuela de políticas
públicas y relaciones internacionales de
la Universidad de British Columbia
gracias a ambas por poner sus
conocimientos en esta mesa de trabajo y
ya regresó con ustedes pero antes
recordarles a nuestros televidentes y
también a las personas que nos escuchan
que hacen parte de este debate dejen sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
nuestras redes sociales
en Twitter en Facebook y en instagram
nos encuentran como arroba France 24
guión bajo s nuestra etiqueta es el
debate f-24 y a mí me encuentran en
Twitter como angelago f24 no olviden que
todos nuestros contenidos están
disponibles para ustedes en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y también
están en TuneIn
y comienza este debate José de un saludo
para usted vamos a comenzar esta
discusión en torno a la reunión de la
unasur una discusión que debía girar
alrededor de las alianzas entre los
países para un fortalecimiento conjunto
y que yo diría se diluyó un poco en la
misma discordia de hace una década
Venezuela y una democracia muy
discutible lo que sucede en Venezuela
para usted es una narrativa porque chile
y Uruguay no están de acuerdo con esa
explicación
bueno Muchas gracias Ángela y parto por
saludar a Grace Jaramillo siempre es un
gusto compartir con ella en estos
debates Y estos foros saludar también a
quienes nos escuchan en este programa
a ver creo que aquí lo más importante es
mirar por primera vez
nuevamente se pone la coyuntura
nuevamente se pone el tema de
integración aunque sea la integración
Sudamericana no latinoamericana estamos
hablando de los países del sur segundo
no fue una reunión de unasur porque
unasur ah es su órgano muerto es una
reunión de doce presidentes
sudamericanos que se sientan a conversar
y creo que es un primer paso en la
dirección correcta para iniciar
conversaciones y Buscar fondos de
cooperación para el desarrollo
hay que reconocer el liderazgo que tiene
el presidente Lula que pudo convocar a
doce presidentes y a los países
sudamericanos después de muchos años de
no conversarse pienso También que fue
desafortunada la elección de palabras
del presidente Lula al señalar la el
tema de Venezuela es una construcción
narrativa sin embargo creo que aquí el
tema no solamente debe girar alrededor
de Venezuela sino también los propios
presidentes
salvo el tema de lo que son temas
importantes como lo que es derechos
humanos y democracia también concordaron
en que era importante sentarse
nuevamente todos los países del cono Sur
a conversar y como le digo Este es un
primer gran paso y ahí asumo
o hago mías las palabras del canciller
chileno
Don Alberto anclave en donde dice que
este es un inicio para hablar sobre
temas de cooperación no se está hablando
de resucitar o no Como algunos quisieran
un organismo de integración o sea es muy
temprano para hablar si se va a poder
resucitar o no la unasur creo que aquí
lo que tenemos que ver y enfocarnos es
en el tema de que por primera vez en una
época de mínimos históricos en la
integración de América Latina Sudamérica
se sienta hablar en una mesa y busca
comunalidades Pero además también va a
ser un ejercicio porque creo que no
solamente se construye a través del
consenso si no se puede construir a
través del disenso
bueno José usted está un poco
adelantándose a otros temas Claro que
tienen que ver por supuesto con con el
encuentro que se dio ayer y con toda su
trascendencia en esta parte del
continente sin embargo Grace quisiera
continuar por un momento con el tema
alrededor de Nicolás maduro porque
quiero entender su opinión sobre esta
declaración de Lula da Silva de que el
discurso alrededor de Venezuela se ha
constituido como una narrativa le decía
a José que claro ni de Uruguay ni chile
estuvieron de acuerdo con que sea una
narrativa y Boris además muy a propósito
apuntó a los cinco mil refugiados
venezolanos que viven en su país y que
necesitan igual que sus líderes una una
posición firme respecto a la crisis que
existe
qué tal Ángela Muchas gracias por la
invitación y también un saludo muy
cordial a Joseph a quien admiro mucho y
con quien hemos trabajado en dos libros
sobre integración ya hace bastante
tiempo hace más de diez años ya van a
ser y justamente ese era el debate que
planteamos en el libro estamos
latinoamericanos integrados o marginados
pero contestando directamente su
pregunta si es que no hubiese habido esa
pre reunión entre bilateral entre
Nicolás maduro y el presidente Lula da
Silva Yo diría que esta reunión esta
primera reunión de conciliación de los
doce presidentes sudamericanos hubiese
sido un gran éxito
pero es precisamente esa reunión y
porque repite esa larga historia de
integrados o fragmentados la que
digamos hace hace esta reunión un
fracaso Por qué Porque
la división la polarización entre
izquierda y derecha es lo que hizo
fracasar ya la unasur y esto como usted
bien dice
elimina totalmente el debate es no es un
debate siquiera ya el hecho de la crisis
en Venezuela de que el autoritarismo no
es una narrativa como bien lo dijo el
presidente Gabriel Boris de chile y es
algo que comparten otros presidentes
social demócratas conservadores en el
Continente entonces además de los miles
de refugiados son ocho millones en total
en el mundo eh cinco mil que están en
chile hay dos millones en el Ecuador hay
tres millones en Perú y no nos olvidemos
del caso de la corte nacional
internacional donde hay reportados ocho
mil novecientos casos de crímenes de
lesa humanidad entonces hay demasiado en
el tapete como evidencia como para
olvidar esa evidencia y yo creo que que
realmente se se dio un disparo en los
pies del presidente Lula al hacer esa
declaración porque ya empezó mal pero la
segunda tema fundamental que hay que
reconocer sobre Venezuela es que sí hay
un consenso de que debemos hacer algo
como latinoamericanos para resolver la
crisis para abrir canales de diálogo
para generar el levantamiento de las
sanciones pero a cambio de una apertura
democrática y de respeto a los Derechos
Humanos Pues usted ilustra muy bien
Grace Cómo ha cambiado el tono de los
líderes latinoamericanos y suramericanos
para este caso en torno a la figura de
Nicolás maduro y a la situación de
derechos humanos de Venezuela porque de
hecho tanto borich como el presidente de
Uruguay a que lo que hay que ver es De
qué manera se va a dar tratamiento a
esta situación es decir una vez más se
revalidando la presencia de Nicolás
maduro en el espacio ahora Lula que
busca además de todo reinstaurar este
papeles de liderazgo de Brasil en los
asuntos exteriores ha rechazado las
críticas a estas declaraciones que dio y
que pues se encendieron los televisores
el día de ayer la pregunta es si
latinoamérica irá a donde vaya a Brasil
o si Suramérica irá a donde vaya a
Brasil ya dando por sentado que Lula
Pues ha tenido su encuentro con maduro y
lo apoya inequívocamente le pregunto
primero a Grace
yo creo que no creo que hay un mal
cálculo del presidente de Brasil en
creer que directamente todos van a
seguir su liderazgo y ya lo ha hecho una
Esta es la segunda vez que trata de
de generar un liderazgo global sin una
estrategia bien pensada el primero fue
en Ucrania donde Ninguno de los
presidentes en cuestión le recibió y ni
siquiera el presidente macron pero esta
es la segunda vez y yo creo que había
que pensar muy bien los pasos antes de
plantear una apertura sin límites y una
aceptación o legitimación del gobierno
de Nicolás maduro de Camino hacia la
integración latinoamericana
en ese sentido yo creo que nadie puede
rechazar un llamado de Brasil Brasil es
la segunda mayor economía de América
Latina una potencia mundial uno de los
miembros de el grupo bricks compro estos
por china
Sudáfrica Rusia e India Entonces no
puede nadie negar una invitación del
presidente Lula pero otra cosa diferente
es tratar de avanzar en un proceso que
es necesariosimo para generar bienes
públicos globales para trabajar
temas de acción colectiva en derechos
humanos en medio ambiente en en comercio
que que están bastante dejados de lado
hacia hacia un ciertamente corto plazo
hay que pensar también en otra en otra
realidad en Sudamérica hay mucha
inestabilidad de por medio Perú Ecuador
son casos dramáticos en donde la
realidad política puede cambiar
radicalmente tienes que queremos pensar
la integración Sudamericana en este
momento yo creo que es una integración
basada y fundamentada en temas de acción
colectiva en temas de bienes públicos
globales no solo regionales como
infraestructura derechos humanos
comercio y ciertamente el medio ambiente
pero nada más no no creo que sea posible
ni viable nada más que funcione
realmente en el corto plazo o mediano
plazo siquiera Bueno vamos a hablar más
adelante sobre el tema comercial y de la
moneda única que no es la primera vez
además que Lula da Silva saca el tema de
a colación desde su retorno al poder o
incluso desde antes pero antes José
usted ha destacado muchísimo esta
importancia de que los líderes se
sienten nuevamente a conversar después
de casi una década en la que la unasur
estaba desmantelada y por diferencias
ideológicas Aunque Venezuela no Debería
ser el centro de toda la complejidad de
relaciones que hay entre los países de
la región Quiero preguntarle por qué la
importancia de todas maneras de incluir
a Venezuela es decir se puede hacer un
bloque común sin este miembro que es lo
que puede aportar Caracas en este
momento para ese desarrollo regional que
están planteando
a ver yo pienso que en el tema de
incluir o no a Venezuela Yo quiero
proyectarme más porque si nos centramos
en Venezuela lo que vamos a hacer es
básicamente ponernos ponernos de una
manera en donde coincidimos en
principios básicos como es el tema de
los Derechos Humanos como bien señaló el
problema de las migraciones el que se
haya demostrado que las sanciones que se
han llevado a cabo tanto de la Unión
Europea como de Estados Unidos a
Venezuela no ha incidido en el bienestar
de las clases que la gobiernan sino
directamente en el pueblo si todo esto
ha fallado creo que hay una posibilidad
de tratar de ver incluyendo y no
excluyendo cómo ese país da los pasos
necesarios para ir implementando un
proceso de regreso o Retorno a la
democracia y eso pasa lógicamente por
construir a través de de por lo menos
ciertos consensos voy en la línea que
dice Grace no en el tema en el tema de
de de incluir a Venezuela
América del Sur le está diciendo y eso
también Debería ser un mensaje de
América Latina al mundo que nosotros
como latinoamericanos o en este momento
los presidentes sudamericanos pueden
buscar soluciones a problemas como el
problema que tiene en este momento
Venezuela Así que es es una una búsqueda
de solución de problemas de América
Latina o de de América del Sur hacia
América del Sur en primer lugar en
segundo lugar creo que el tema sobre
buscar nuevos fondos de cooperación nace
es una propuesta del sur global y eso
también es muy importante reconocerlo
porque en este momento los fondos de
cooperación van a venir de fuentes
bastante más distintas de las que está
acostumbrada a recibir la región de
socios o aliados estratégicos históricos
Entonces pienso que
incluir o no incluir a Venezuela
no no viene a ser un punto de inflexión
en este primer paso y yo ahí sí quiero
señalar que pienso que no sabemos si va
a tener éxito o no Aún es muy temprano
nuevamente es señalar la importancia de
que se sentaran en una mesa a dialogar a
conversar a pesar de sus diferencias a
pesar de sus
distanciamientos ideológicos doce
presidentes en áreas de hacer una hoja
de ruta que permita en un contexto donde
ya la misma cepal ha señalado que la
región va a decrecer económicamente
Buscar la posibilidad de de crear una
hoja de ruta común que genere fondos de
desarrollo para el bienestar de las de
los pueblos sudamericanos creo que eso
es lo que lo lo importante de esta
convocatoria Bueno entonces José en ese
sentido lo que podemos hacer es dar por
terminado el tema de Nicolás maduro y
vamos a avanzar hacia otros temas que
les competen a los líderes y sobre este
tema de los fondos y demás temas que
quieren llevar adelante como el tema
ambiental como el tema comercial pues
son temas que toman tiempo no Y como
esta reunión Usted lo ha dicho es muy
pronto es muy temprano apenas es un
primer acercamiento para ver quiénes
somos y en qué estamos
a mí me surge una gran pregunta
alrededor de este encuentro Y es que
Lula dijo que esta integración
suramericana se vio interrumpida de
forma abrupta por los gobiernos
conservadores como en el caso de su
antecesor Yahir bolsonaro Y aquí pues
quisiera preguntarle ustedes mismas han
dicho que esta es una zona evidentemente
convulsa hay manera de plantear una base
de unidad que se salga de un esquema
ideológico de un esquema en este caso de
las izquierdas y que pueda mantenerse
vigente aún cuando llegue la alternancia
política a Joseph
a ver a mí me parece que el problema que
tenemos Y eso lo dejó muy claro
la pandemia o la sindemia que vivimos
los los mapas conceptuales para entender
las las tendencias mundiales cambiaron
los que teníamos para interpretar la la
región o el mundo ya no son los mismos
que quedaron totalmente
superados necesitamos nuevos mapas
conceptuales Y eso pasa por no mirar o
hacer análisis aunque cueste muchísimo a
través de la ideologización eso fue o es
lo que ha ido matando o ha ido puesto en
situaciones casi que de de críticas
todas las los mecanismos de integración
de América Latina y de América Latina
entonces a ver
lo que lo lo que yo considero en en este
en este en este periodo es
no es a través de de consensos
específicos en en todo sino en en buscar
como decía el el famoso libro de
relaciones internacionales de
arthursstein no Por qué cooperan las
naciones y las naciones cooperan por dos
razones básicamente por intereses y por
circunstancias Bueno hay un interés en
Buscar fondos de cooperación para el
desarrollo eso los une segundo las
circunstancias la región según las
proyecciones de cepal va a crecer un uno
punto si mal no recuerdo dos por ciento
o sea eso está muy por debajo cada vez
Se bajan las proyecciones si usted no
tiene
producción si usted no tiene inversión
extranjera Y si usted no tiene fondos
usted no puede invertir en el desarrollo
y eso le va a generar
el que se le vaya acabando
indistintamente si es un gobierno de
derecha es un gobierno de izquierda o si
son extremos conservadores o de de de
extremas izquierdas usted no va a tener
el consenso de sus pueblos para poder
gobernar Y creo que eso es algo de
sentido Como así que pienso que aquí lo
más importante es Buscar esos intereses
estas circunstancias y construir e ir
construyendo sobre esa base que se pueda
lograr va a ser difícil pero ya tienen
la experiencia o ya sabemos lo que pasa
cuando se ideologiza la integración en
la región de América Latina del Caribe
están llamadas a fracasar y por eso Mi
pregunta es querer resucitar a un muerto
si todavía están las Los ejes
transversales del de la ideología se va
a poder resucitar o sea es muy difícil
en este momento hacer un análisis o
llegar a una conclusión porque apenas se
está iniciando y yo sí quiero recalcar
como dice Grace después seguir el pulso
de la integración de de la región por
tanto tiempo sí quiero Resaltar esta
primera reunión como un paso importante
que marca por lo menos las buenas
intenciones de construir una hoja de
ruta para Sudamérica en en áreas de
Buscar fondos frescos de cooperación
bueno Grace lo dijo el presidente
argentino Alberto Fernández el que
defendió que se mantuviera una Unión de
Naciones suramericanas unasur pero sin
ideologías y con un funcionamiento más
ágil Usted qué opina de de ese ideal que
también expresa yo sé de y que Del dicho
al hecho pues Tendría que haber mucho
camino y mucha no solo cooperación sino
coordinación entre las naciones
involucradas
bueno es que por eso Hemos trabajado
tantos años con con Joseph en estos
temas ella Desde la integración
centroamericana pero también siempre en
Venezuela como conexión por su conexión
al Caribe y también la conexión a
América del Sur Pero es verdad y y hay
dos cosas particulares que la audiencia
puede tomar en cuenta yo creo que la
integración regional en América Latina
siempre va en círculos es como que uno
repite la historia y a veces se olvida
de retomar la historia pasada El ejemplo
más claro Precisamente en el espacio
sudamericano son dos dos instancias que
hasta ahora hasta el momento de hoy en
temas que importan es decir desarrollo
económico y además de integración
comercial son importantísimas el
mercosur que además está negociando un
tratado de libre comercio con la Unión
Europea en este momento y la comunidad
andina todavía funcionan todavía
funcionan en ese espacio estructural de
el intercambio económi
y la lección de estos de estas dos
instancias regionales que funcionaron en
su momento pero que siguen funcionando
es que siempre se quitó el tema de qué
color político tenía el presidente de
turno que asistía a las cumbres
presidenciales o los ministros que
asistían ya sea a las cumbres de
comercio de ministros de comercio o las
cumbres de cancilleres Yo creo que esa
lección histórica de Por qué funcionó Y
por qué siguió funcionando estas dos
instancias de integración pueden ser
retomadas por Brasil y los demás
miembros de este grupo sudamericano que
empieza es importantísimo que empiece
este diálogo porque sí se olvidan esos
colores políticos o ideologías políticas
Esto va a fluir mucho más crecientemente
como vemos los cambios políticos en las
elecciones son muy fluctuantes no no
sabemos si quién sucederá el presidente
boric será alguien de derecha o de
izquierda o de extrema izquierda o de
extrema derecha lo mismo pasa en Ecuador
lo mismo pasa en Perú Colombia y quién
sabe si Argentina en este en los años
que vendrá
por eso decía que esta segunda punto
fundamental va a ser concentrarse en los
temas que necesitan ser resueltos
urgentemente cambio climático se me
ocurre infraestructura se me ocurre y la
tercera importantísima que afecta a
todos los presidentes seguridad interna
bueno y todos estos temas también
tendrían una relación con una de las
ideas centrales que ha expresado Lula da
Silva y es este este tema de tener una
moneda única y dejar de tener una
dependencia tan alta del dólar analistas
diversos muchos de ellos que han
visitado France 24 coinciden en la
dificultad incluso a largo plazo de
implementarla con países que uno
ostentan reglas Fiscales tan distintas y
que tienen situaciones inflacionarias
también tan variadas y pasamos desde
Argentina hasta Brasil pasando por
Colombia o Ecuador Usted qué opina yo sé
de esta idea de la moneda única para
instalarla en un largo plazo y dar los
pasos hacia ese lugar
bueno Es una muy buena idea es una muy
linda idea y sería maravilloso que
funcionara pero yo coincido con las
personas que señalan que tiene primero
que nada grandes desafíos que implicaría
hacer arreglos internos dentro de la
gran diversidad heterogeneidad y
pluralidad porque se manejan las
economías de nuestra región como para
que esto diera Fuera fuera una medida
exitosa entonces a ver vamos vamos a
señalar como idea es fenomenal
ponerla en práctica es el gran desafío y
me parece que en este momento pues
no no se vislumbraría que fuera a corto
mediano plazo sino a muy muy largo plazo
y dependiendo además de cómo funcionen
todas estas iniciativas que están
haciendo del sur global y sobre todo hay
que ver cómo funcionan los temas de los
brics que ahí yo sí quiero señalar miren
ustedes que parte de lo que trató
Brasil fue de incorporar Argentina los
brics y no le fue posible en esta
ocasión
Grace Usted qué opina sobre esta
consecución de una moneda única Y es que
también Lula ha instado a los bancos
estatales a que empiecen a trabajar
juntos para financiar el desarrollo esto
puede tener que ver con los fondos de
cooperación que menciona Joseph
Bueno ahí sí Joseph Yo creo que es una
muy mala idea si vemos cómo lo logró
Europa fue un trabajo extremadamente
delicado de tratar de coordinar o hacer
coordinación macrofiscal al detalle
creando un barco un Banco Central
europeo creando también coordinaciones
macroeconómicas con todos los ministros
de finanzas de toda la Unión Europea ya
vemos lo que sucedió con Grecia ahorita
están en en disputa con Italia y casi
todos los países de Europa del este
siguen en en problemas para tratar de
adecuar sus economías a las estrictos
requerimientos de una moneda única eso
en América Latina y cuando ni siquiera
podemos generar estos mecanismos de
acción colectiva para temas básicos como
seguridad como infraestructura Vial y de
telecomunicaciones que hoy en día es la
economía del futuro imagínense tratar de
coordinar políticas macrofiscales sin ni
siquiera entre los miembros del Alba eso
se pudo hacer el ejemplo claro es
Bolivia Bolivia siempre estuvo
estrictamente
alineada con una política fiscal más
bien conservadora mientras nosotros
países no O sea no solo que hacían
contra sí políticas contra cíclicas sino
cíclicas en el sentido de invertir más
de lo que tenían en en cualquier tipo de
proyectos y ya fracasó el banco del sur
el banco del sur fracasó entre otras
razones porque solo Brasil puso el
dinero nadie más quería poner el dinero
ni siquiera para pagar personal
yo creo que empezar por ahí es y empezar
mal si es que convencen a todos los
países de manejar los temas
consistentemente los temas que se puede
manejar los temas que se puede coordinar
donde ya hay experiencia por ejemplo el
irse el la iniciativa de infraestructura
Sudamericana que funcionó muy bien
incluso con bancos como
y otras ayudas del Banco Mundial bueno
podríamos empezar por ahí pero sí el una
moneda común en este momento hablarla de
esa manera Es una muy mala idea porque
por estas razones es que se creó prosur
y y se dividió la unión Sudamericana
porque nadie quería ser parte del banco
del sur entre otra razón bueno la
respuesta o una de las respuestas sí
chosette quería hacer una intervención
claro pequeña en eso Grace este
coincidimos lo que no coincidimos es en
que una dijo una buena idea y otra dijo
una mala idea pero al final creo que al
fin coincidimos en señalar que sería una
buena idea Si tuviera la posibilidad de
realizarse el tema es todo lo que
señalaste y la experiencia que hay en la
región sobre sobre el discurso o sea es
una buena idea cómo se sustenta esa
buena idea es el desafío que tiene y ahí
es donde diferimos en el tema que sea
bueno o mala pero pero coincidimos
en el análisis de Por qué si se si se
aplica en el momento o si se mira la
historia está llamada a fracasar
Bueno pues es que sería maravilloso no
tener que depender del dólar para las
transacciones y de hecho sabemos que ya
se están llegando algunos acuerdos para
no depender del dólar algunos países
están buscando pasarse a los yuanes Pero
bueno
concordamos probablemente en la
dificultad en un continente en una parte
del continente tan diversa y con tantas
fluctuaciones en los líderes que suben
al poder ya llegando al final de esta
conversación que por cierto pues ha
iluminado bastante lo que está pasando
en las salas internacionales quisiera
pedirle Grace su balance al final
positivo o negativo de este primer
acercamiento y que se espera para los
que vengan
mi balance es excelente idea mala
estrategia para empezar precisamente por
el tema de por cómo se puso el tema de
Venezuela lo que podemos esperar es que
el trabajo del grupo de contacto y esa
es una sugerencia que desde ya seguro
que Joseph apoya es que el grupo de
contacto no se que analiza la
posibilidad a la viabilidad de este
diálogo sudamericano no se remita
solamente a cancilleres y y salas
diplomáticas de los países sudamericanos
sino que se amplía la sociedad civil a
los académicos que hemos estudiado por
muchos años estos temas para que podamos
hacer el mejor balance posible con con
un balance de de las experiencias
pasadas pero sobre todo Qué podría
funcionar hoy y en corto mediano y largo
plazo
de cara al futuro Lo importante es
concentrarse ya no en temas electorales
domésticos etcétera
sino en los temas que importan derechos
humanos
comercio cooperación internacional
seguridad que que Son imprescindibles
pero también son urgentes para todos los
gobiernos independientemente de su tinte
ideológico Gracias por la oportunidad No
gracias rápidamente Es que no quiero
dejar fuera el tema de la seguridad de
que las dos han mencionado Cuáles cree
que deberían ser los principales
problemas en torno a seguridad que
deberían abordar los líderes en sus
encuentros a venir
si usted analizan en latino barómetro y
otros mecanismos de encuestas regionales
en todos los países los presidentes han
perdido credibilidad y y apoyo ciudadano
porque la primera preocupación de casi
todos los ciudadanos en América Latina
No se diga en Sudamérica es la violencia
ciudadana la el crimen organizado
etcétera etcétera
parte de del resquebrajamiento de una
relación a nivel latinoamericano Y
sudamericano es que los mecanismos
policiales e inteligencia no comparte o
deja de compartir información y a mí me
consta porque parte de ese fue el
problema después de el ataque de
Angostura por parte de Colombia en
Ecuador donde se rompieron lazos de
compartir información sobre crimen
organizado en la región uno de el sol o
sea usar el mecanismo de integración
regional para resolver un problema tan
fundamental me parece que es de primer
orden en la la prioridad que deberían
tener los presidentes latinoamericanos
y finalmente Joseph balance positivo o
negativo después de este encuentro que
usted ha llamado incansablemente
preliminar haciendo muy bien la
diferenciación de que podría o no ser un
desastre o un rotundo éxito
pienso que es un balance positivo Porque
además en esto el presidente Lula y y la
coyuntura O sea tiene muy claro que
alguien tenía que asumir el liderazgo Y
eso implica asumirlo con Los costos
tanto económicos como políticos pero lo
más importante es este inicio de
conversaciones y tal y como lo señalaba
Grace y un poco en la línea de lo que yo
señalaba de crear nuevos mapas
conceptuales si los
gobernantes quieren contar con hojas de
ruta que los ayude a enfrentar los
nuevos desafíos globales que son
bastante complejos pues tienen que
buscar alianzas
estratégicas con actores fuera del
ámbito político o fuera de sí mismos Así
que yo sí insto O me gustaría pensar que
además de de
del encuentro con cancilleres se puede
incluir a la Academia que puede ser un
socio estratégico en esta construcción
de nuevos mapas conceptuales para hacer
hojas de ruta que le convengan a la
región pero también hay que tomar en
consideración de que el un liderazgo
subregional porque estamos hablando de
Sudamérica
implica asumir costos
en todo sentido costos económicos y
costos políticos habrá que ver si el
presidente Lula que se está queriendo
posicionar en esto y tiene Brasil como
señalabares tiene el peso para convocar
ASUME ASUME también esos esos desafíos
pero yo yo lo veo muy muy positivo lo
veo lo veo bien y tal como señalaba
Grace creo que es importante en el tema
de defensa hay que quitar la seguridad
del enfoque de los problemas
del crimen organizado y los problemas
que están golpeando tanto el tema de
seguridad a nivel de la región y empezar
a usar otro también aparte del de la
seguridad de la defensa otro tipo de
análisis que también tiene que ver con
el tema social Ah y analizar más más a
fondo el Por qué se siguen dando estos
problemas entonces
Creo que creo que vamos creo que que que
que vamos por buen camino pues un
agradecimiento muy especial para Joseph
dalmara Borbón y secretaria general de
la facultad latinoamericana de ciencias
sociales y a la doctora Grace Jaramillo
profesora de la escuela de políticas
públicas y relaciones internacionales de
la Universidad de British Columbia
muchas gracias a ustedes pero también
Muchísimas gracias a nuestros
televidentes una vez más Eso es todo por
hoy En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos por su sintonía la
producción de este programa estuvo a
cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y la de
nuestras invitadas a cargo de Tania
Herrera Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en nuestras
redes sociales nos vemos pronto
[Música]